the queen lying in state entry to the
queue has now reopened after being
paused earlier but there's a warning of
a 24-hour wait
David Beckham joined the queue for 12
hours with the crowds before paying his
respects to her majesty
it's emotional for um for everybody
involved you know to obviously um
thing to be here to to you know to
celebrate the way we we have done with
everybody today I think it's been a it's
been a special day
foreign
[Music]
consort attended a remembrance service
for Queen Elizabeth Atlanta Cathedral
before heading to the Senate to
acknowledge acknowledge condolences from
members of the Welsh Parliament
I take up my new duties with immense
gratitude for the privilege of having
been able to serve as Prince of Wales
and the new Prince and Princess of Wales
met troops in Surrey involved in the
Queen's State funeral
okay here we go
evening tonight the late Queen's
children once again stood guard around
her body following the king and queen
consort's visit to the Welsh Senate
neither they nor the British people show
any sign of flagging in this
extraordinary sustained tribute to her
majesty
the queue in the capital is now 24 hours
long and there are still almost three
days to go before the climax of these
rituals
world leaders are starting to arrive
some already bowing their heads in
Westminster Hall
but in this in the peculiar combination
of ancient deference and modern
democracy the most prominent mourner
today was a star of The People's game
David Beckham queued for 12 hours from 2
A.M this morning
baffling it may seem to many especially
those viewing abroad but here it feels
utterly natural and utterly British
let's speak now to Sky's Laura bundock
and also Wesley Kerr former Royal
correspondent and um let's start with
the vigil which ended about an hour ago
this is not new is it Wesley such an
incredibly powerful occasion so it goes
back to 1936 when Edward VII LED his
brothers
um the Duke of York of course that was
to be king later that year the Duco came
to the Duke of Gloucester in
memorializing another incredibly popular
Monarch George V who had died at
Sandringham in in January of that year
and that that was a vigil at Westminster
Hall the first king to have a lying in
state in in recent years at Westminster
Hall was Edward the seventh but this
this this really captured people's
imagination George V was immensely
popular he'd become the idea of the
Christmas broadcast in 1932 amazingly
only eight years before Elizabeth's
first broadcast during the war and he
was seen as very very avuncular and here
were his rather handsome Sons at the
beginning of sort of mass media convert
judging around his tomb then it happened
again in 1952 with male members of the
family around the The Queen's father and
it happened with the queen mother but
what was unique this time was that it
previously had been just male princes
um on this occasion the Princess Royal
was there and she had a stick she was
there as gold stick in Waiting not a not
a walking stick but they did look in
um and I thought that the prince of the
King was was would tear up in fact it
was incredibly poignant the schedule
that he's had
um I suppose it would be noted that um
the Duke of York was in uniform I
personally don't have a problem with
that on this one occasion tomorrow he
wasn't he was uh serving naval officer
in in the Falcons well we'll come back
to that Laura you've been following the
uh siblings all week this is um
an incredibly grueling schedule and then
to come out again tonight I know it
feels non-stop we've had day after day
first after first for the king this
enormously frantic tour of the nation so
we've seen him in Scotland straight onto
Northern Ireland and then a day off
yesterday but there is no such thing as
a day off when you are monarch there
will be red books there will be all
sorts of things to be dealing with you
know he's taking calls from heads of
state and the likes and then today
arriving in Cardiff lots of meetings
audiences Services politicians and it
seems quite fitting almost at the end of
what has been an incredible what's over
a week now isn't it it sort of
culminates tonight with this very quiet
personal
almost private moment except it is
played out completely in public so the
cameras were there the crowds were there
and I I thought about the crowds
actually those people who've been
queuing for hours and hours what a
moment to be filing through Westminster
Hall to pay thanks to the the queen and
then to find all of her four children
standing vigil by the coffin as well but
I think you can see from her children's
point of view this was very much a
moment they wanted to Mark and to
support the king as well it was
interesting when you look at what Prince
Edward Yale of Wessex had to say in the
statement he released the very emotional
personal statement earlier he said the
bass on she carried for these for 70
years now passes to the Next Generation
and to my brother Charles and it was
interesting to see the other members of
the family watching on almost as a
supporting
acts and all the wider royal family that
used to see on the balcony so that I
think is what's really astonishing and
it's the power of Monica if it works for
you which is you've got this intimacy
and you've got this intergenerational
thing it renewed but but in the public
gaze but they seem this family to be
able to cope with that because all of us
all of those people there today though
those four have had it their whole life
I was gonna say there's an interesting
thing emerging here isn't there a queen
in reality
um when Princess Margaret was
essentially stepped back a bit from the
a lot of the official duties was the
queen and there was a prince uh the
Prince Philip next to her all-time that
was the image we now have the king
and by the way we haven't mentioned the
queen consort who has been by his side
every minute of the public apparently
so it said yes wow okay well I have to
say something
no sign of it she's 75 yes but what's
interesting is that we see with the
siblings a kind of emergence of a maybe
a little hierarchy Princess Anne she
came with she accompanied the Queen's
body all the way through the Duke and
Duchess of Wessex have been
out there and they've represented I
think the The Duchess of West Texas in
some sense it represented the Queen
the contest of West Sophie was very very
close to the queen so bagshot places
close to Windsor and their children are
much younger than the other
grandchildren so they've been able to
spend a lot more time
um Louise and James with with the queen
which was a point that was made in the
statement but by by Edward today and
they may be come Duke and Duchess of
Edinburgh and um and of course the
reason man has been so prominent she's
you know there's this intergeneration
you know that she's 10 years older than
the the two brothers so at the beginning
of the last Reign there was a new us
four it was Philip Elizabeth Charles and
Anne and Anne you know I met her many
times is such a Charming person
incredibly hard working does more
engagements in fact than Charles so as
well as the new Quad quadrum with the
Wales is you you've got these empowered
siblings I mean the Duke of York just
for today yes let's not go through that
there's sorry Laura you wanted to no no
I think I think it's the point isn't it
I think you see the siblings stepping up
and the princess role is always we know
she's carried out you know more more
official duties anyone else getting on
with it but very much wanting to be
there to support I think her big brother
basically that the two older siblings
meant to be close the people close to
them have told me that you know they do
have a close relationship they do speak
regularly on the phone I'm obviously see
each other at Big functions of life but
they are you know the growing up you
know at the same time there is a big age
gap between between them and the other
two and I think you can see that the way
they move together and and and the fact
the king I think will rely on that
support as well this is a huge moment
for him okay with Camilla and as well
okay
tens of thousands of mourners continue
to visit the queen lying in state
earlier the queue was so long entry was
paused and a cue to the queue formed
people are now being warned it could
take as long as 24 hours to get to the
front
well David Beckham was among those
standing in line with members of the
public he told us he'd waited for over
12 hours to pay his respects
the queue begins at Westminster Hall
where there is airport style security
from there it winds its way back through
Victoria Tower Gardens on the embankment
and across Lambeth Bridge
for those who require it an accessible
route is available starting at Tate
Britain where timed entry slots are
issued but by midday this was at
capacity
on the opposite side of the River Thames
the main queue stretches along the South
Bank past the London Eye and the Tate
modern back to London Bridge
the queue has a maximum permitted length
at southwark Park in burmandy where
entry was paused earlier today
reports now on the Westminster queue
and not the warmest of welcomes for
those joining it
thousands like Alistair are undeterred
by the weight or the walk
Her Majesty gave us 70 years what's
giving her nine hours that's nothing
despite being five miles from
Westminster turning back was never an
option for Alison from Richmond in
Yorkshire who's honoring a promise to
her late mum I'd worked 21 hours for her
when I was very little me and my mom
said we would come to this my mum's
passed away so I'm here for her and
Nanny aren't we yeah
many are making this pilgrimage for
their loved ones and when that
opportunity looks like it's slipping
away frustration comes to the fall sit
on the line
they should have known crowds were
temporarily halted for safety
I'm not sure
it came after 20 minutes much to their
relief
[Music]
snaking through southwark Park is taking
on average three hours every so often
pressure is relieved on the pens and the
queue surges forward by another 100
meters it is overwhelming when you first
enter But morale is high people expected
it
so they marched on among them football
legend David Beckham have you been
waiting long David folks a little while
what time did you join the queue uh
quarter past two
who likes so many in those precious
seconds was overcome
I think it's emotional for um for
everybody involved you know to obviously
um
the thing to be here to to you know to
celebrate the way we we have done with
everybody today I think it's been a it's
been a special day but it's not without
its challenges by Night Safety in the
queue becomes more demanding dozens have
been taken to hospital after fainting
and there's been a sexual assault charge
for someone waiting in line as
temperatures dip the resilience of
thousands is tested as they now face a
24-hour wait
Sky News in southeast London
Skye started charity he joins us from
the carriage gates in Westman so good
evening Sergio
evening this is the exit so this is when
people have already had that very long
queue gone into Westminster Hall paid
their respects and then made their way
out and you can see just how festive the
atmosphere here is and I'm joined Now by
Susan and libler thank you very much for
joining us you guys met in the queue we
did we did from 7 30 this morning
we've kept together all the way through
there were 13 of us all together lots of
girls came on their own so we all women
were all together and there were 13 of
us so it's just been amazing
extraordinary experience and then to
culminate in what we saw absolutely so
the time must have flown past with 13 of
you all chatting away it was hilarious
it did help it didn't help stories yes
yeah shared food shared drinks yeah it
was great excellent what was that moment
like once you entered Westminster Hall
very moving yeah Reverend
um hugely respectful the way the hush
happened the way everybody just went
individually to their own heart and I
think we all just yeah it was just worth
every every step it was so wonderful why
is it so important it's such a big
moment in history but why is it so
important to you
because it's once in a lifetime this
will never happen again it's like seeing
the century out all these famous people
that's gone
yeah just felt that we wanted to be here
and for a lot of people that we've
spoken to they've said that the queen
had reminded them of their mother or
their grandmother or and things like
that is that the case with you
absolutely my dad yeah mum everyone
that's passed it just brings it back I
think um she's always been around she's
just been a constant and so therefore
you know you kind of looked to her and
her values were so extraordinary that it
was um a pledge well I made a pledge
that try and just be like her
excellent thank you so much for speaking
to us and good luck on your journey home
thank you thanks very much
we're just like Susan and her friend
there lots of people have passed through
here today
um and you can see now on this side if
we just swing across to my rights lots
of people still waiting and many of them
had arrived hours ago to catch a glimpse
of the king and his siblings as they
made their way through to here and loads
of people that are still coming out this
is of course a 24-hour queue and
there'll be more people exiting as we go
on there are some times where they stop
the queue just to let other things
happen and changing of the guards and
things like that but you'll see you'll
notice lots of people there quite
emotional as they're coming out a short
while ago we we saw some volunteers
handing out tissues many people in their
military attire some people dressed in
black but most of all you have to notice
their Footwear most mostly people coming
in very comfortable Footwear because it
is a long wait and that wait time does
change it's gone up to 24 hours we've
seen it go to 12 hours 22 and when you
ask people all sorts of different times
that they've entered the queue but a
real sentiment here that it has been a
very emotional time but a cue where
they've made friends the time has passed
quite quickly but are very important to
be here for this very important part of
History
Sadia thank you very much indeed
[Music]
to have a look at the live pictures from
Westminster Hall where people are still
processing through in a steady stream
for those who are still hoping to join
this is the Q tracker provided by the
department for digital culture media and
Sport the length of the queue is no
longer being announced but the wait time
is and currently that is estimated at
around 22 hours
if you scan the QR code on your screen
right now you can watch a live stream of
the Queen's lying in state in full on
the Sky News website and mobile apps
Laura bundock and Wesley Carr are with
me once again
um
it's extraordinary Laura the energy that
you can see of the people who have been
standing there
or actually shuffling through for 10
hours and then as a contrast what's
interesting is when they come out very
silent yes I think it is interesting
because you've got people making these
odd friendships in the queue but bonded
very very strongly by a shared sense of
wanting to be there and so it's
interesting seeing the two women we saw
who just come out together they'd been
with a group of 13 women they'd never
known each other before they started
hearing and they'd all become friends
and I think there is a sort of sense
we'll get each other through the queue
however long it be 12 24 hours and then
of course that moment hits you as you
walk into Westminster Hall this huge
imposing building and you walk down the
steps and then have those few very short
but important moments where you then
have to consider how you will react how
you'll respond and it's fascinating
watching that response in people I think
people have changed I've been monitoring
the pictures all day I've had friends in
the queue and I've spoken to people for
after they've come out and you sort of
emotion coming through the text or the
phone and there's something of the
atmosphere of a medieval Shrine I mean
it's interesting that the the funeral
like the coronation will take place just
next to the shrine of Saint Edward the
Confessor
um which is where about 11 British
monarchs are around that Shrine so
there's a lot of people are crossing
themselves they're not cursing they're
genuflecting they're praying and you see
people as they come down the stairs you
see their expression change and they're
they're having a very powerful moment
and I think it's a very powerful
national moment it may not involve
everybody but just to pause the clock
for 10 days it's been quite a strifeful
few years in this country
um and
if the Constitution people want what is
our constitution well we've seen the
Constitution we see that they're human
beings at the center of it so I think
that um I think our country has been
changed by this experience but we're
learning something and actually in some
ways
um I won't go so far as to say making it
up as we go along but what is very
interesting is I don't think there's any
protocol about what people do when they
get into Westminster hall or how they
make a a signal or what they do but what
seems very interesting if you watch it
for any length of time is that there's a
whole range of ways and people
acknowledge the moment but everyone
seems to be okay they don't get their
phones up they're not allowed to they
don't jabber there's they're silent
um their body language I would say has
changes I mean it is the most
astonishing room for many years it was
the biggest room in England built in the
Western Hall yeah built in in the 1090s
by William the conquerors sun and
Elizabeth is the 41st monitor since
we're in the Conqueror so that part of
continuity and probably most these
people have never been in that Hall so
so the change from being outside to
being there but but I I might it's an
incredibly powerful and it's going on
for long than it's ever gone before the
Queen's father like lay in state just
for three days but you see people it is
almost a jaw drop as they come down the
steps and then it confronts them and and
the Catapult itself is high up isn't it
so there is a sort of sense of majesty
just by the presentation of everything
the crown the orb the scepter last scene
actually in Westminster Abbey at a
service for these six I think 60th
anniversary of the correlation that I
was at but to see them in such close
proximity and the thing with the crown
in particular it actually Sparkles when
you're it's brilliantly lit somebody was
saying to me who was there for the king
in 1952 that he was like actually in a
spotlight the hall was dark so this is
modern lighting but it's actually rather
clever and subtle writing but that Crown
Sparkles that Auburn scepter that
standard and that wonderful word
catafolk it just looks magnificent it's
definitely very theatrical too indeed
there is something about the setting and
the environment and no it has clearly
been designed but we've all been
remarking on the well of emotion here
and as I was going to
um Steve Riker the professor of social
psychology who specializes in behavior
of groups crown and so on and he said
that he thought that
one part of what is going on here is
that for many people particularly those
who have arrived in person
this moment is evoking something about
themselves and their own history people
are remembering their own parents death
for example I think it I think very much
it is holding a mirror to your own
moments a personal mourning and seeing
it played out on such a national stage
like this is a way that you look inside
and you see an echo You Feel The Echoes
of how you felt when you lost a close
loved one very much so and I think
that's what monarchy does but and this
woman is the apogee of monarchy and we
all I mean many of us did know her but
everybody feels they did know her and
because of the you know the staging of
this and the amount of ceremonial the
amount of appearances and you know I
think millions of people are able
physically to participate and that will
culminate I would have thought you know
what a million maybe for the funeral
another million on the route it looks
like one of the Striking successes here
that they've
varied the pageantry to include the
emotion which was not always the case in
the past but anyway we'll talk about
this again
earlier King Charles along with the
queen consulate Camilla made a trip to
Wales completing the final leg of his
tour of the home nations of the United
Kingdom
the king who was of course Prince of
Wales for 64 years spoke in Welsh to
members of the Senate and attended a
service of prayer and reflection for the
queen of clandauf Cathedral
he spoke to those who'd gathered to see
him with some singing God Save the King
Dan Whitehead reports now on the king in
Wales
they staked around the castle walls from
the early hours
thousands waited to see their prince now
King on his first visit to Wales we got
up very early this morning but Jaden
obviously didn't sleep all night because
he was so excited to see the king so
we've been up quite early and we
traveled down by train uh Jaden what is
it that you're so excited about I'm
really excited to shape the king's hand
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
and long live the queen and king I just
wanted them to remember a historic
moment you know when our new King has
come into Wales
while the queue grew longer two miles
away the king and queen consort began
their day at landaf Cathedral for a
service of remembrance
the king signed the visitor book this
time bringing his own pen after leaky
ink issues earlier in the week
the pair then met local school children
before heading on to the Senate
condolences from the Welsh Parliament
before addressing it in their own
language
it must surely be counted the greatest
privilege to belong to a land that could
Inspire such devotion
I am resolved to honor that selfless
example in the spirit of the words
by which I have always tried to live my
own life I serve
from politics to the people the Royals
made their way to the waiting crowds
inside Cardiff Castle
[Applause]
meetings with dignitaries and the first
Minister even time for a much needed
pick-me-ups
but it wasn't long before the wait was
over for those outside many finally
getting to shake the new King's hand
it's amazing
it was really special did you get to
shake yes yes and the queen Camilla as
well that was important dude it's nice
for him to have a memory of it because I
remember the queen when I was little
missing the queen and so for him to meet
the king and it's history isn't it but
not all we're happy
struggle to heat our homes we have to
pay for your parade
all support the monarchy here in Wales
thousands have turned out to greet the
new king and the queen consort in what's
being described as a day of transition
for this country
the next generation will grow up with
King Charles the former Prince of this
nation now starting a new journey in his
relationship with Wales
don't watch it Sky News in Cardiff
[Music]
Laura bundock and wetika are with me
once again Laura are you hot footed it
down from Wales I can't imagine how you
got here but um
what what was your impression of the day
there
um it was another busy day and it moved
from the uh this is the spiritual to the
political having had the service and
then obviously the political meeting at
the Senate and then
various audiences at the castle but for
me I think the moments that stand out
the crowd moments really and I think
that's why people were gathered there
from very early this morning wanting to
catch sight of the king who of course up
until very recently had been Prince of
Wales and Prince of Wales since the age
of nine so he'd had a long connection
with Wales but returning to the country
almost like his homeland if you like now
as head of state as the Monarch so it
was interesting watching the reaction
there and he spoke very fondly about his
mother's very close relationship with
the country how he obviously making
Prince William the new Prince of Wales
hopes to continue the sort of ancient
title really but you know he'll be well
aware of the sensitivities of everything
there as well he's long learned the
Traditions the culture the history of
Wales so he will know that it's it is
one thing to have a prince of Wales but
what that role means and how it should
be defined a sort of problems and
challenges facing Prince William Wesley
we've um seen now Edinburgh and Belfast
and Cardiff where do you think this week
leaves the union and the crowned
relationship with the state of the union
is definitely is stronger I mean Her
Majesty's death in Balmoral the fact
that nearly half of these remarkable
ceremonies have taken place in Scotland
um which which the Prince of Wales as he
was the king loves he was there and was
already there
um I think that and and
um the prince the new Prince of Wales
has talked of his love of Scotland how
so many important events in his life
happened there I I think I think it I
think you know there's supposed to be a
referendum next year I mean maybe that
maybe maybe that the Supreme Court will
rule it up which might happen but but I
um I think that he's shown the new king
great sensitivity to all the nuances
he's had the right words he's had a bit
of Robbie Burns in one place the London
Dairy Aaron another place speaking Welsh
and he's he's taken the regional
assemblies and the Scottish Parliament
and then extremely seriously
um so I I think that that's been a
fantastic part of his fantastic and
Brilliant week despite all the sorrow
the other thing that we've seen emerging
today is if you like the issue of faith
and actually in each case he has
attended a service
and he has expressed his own faith his
devoutness uh he used the word devout
himself
um and he met Faith leaders this evening
Laura
um
this seems a much more upfront
profession of Faith than we're used to I
think from the royal family yeah there's
been a lot of talk for some time now as
to whether or not he would be to
offender of the faith or Defender of
faith and I think by saying that today
in front of those leaders that I am a
committed Anglican Christian as he put
it made it very clear that he would be
defender of the faith but with this huge
huge addition to that saying that he
recognized a duty to protect the
diversity of our country including
protecting the space for Faith itself
and I think you get a sense there that
he is pushing this further that by how
by being defender of the faith and
asserting himself there that puts him in
a stronger position when it comes to the
inclusivity be it other faiths or even
kind of secular kind of it's all there
basically he had no choice as the title
it was a title given to Henry VII in
fact for attacking Martin Luther but
it's enshrined in the Tudor Constitution
that he's defender of faith and he is of
course Supreme governor of the Church of
England
um very important one of his title
um so his mother made a speech towards
the end of her Reign saying that her
position of defender of Faith was a kind
of umbrella for people of all faiths and
none so I think that that's very very
important pivoting to Modern Britain and
this expression community of communities
once controversial I think that shows
that he's absolutely in tune with the
debates there and determined to be
everybody's leader everybody's King so
he couldn't be making more effort to be
conciliatory and to include people
of course a lot of people who would say
really this whole idea of religion being
an inalienable a kind of completely
legitimate part of um you know the
social landscape
we should back off on that but he's
doubling down isn't he well it's
actually intrinsic to the Constitution
as we saw the privy Council so so yeah
this very very ancient state has was
torn apart by religious wars you know
and and the lessons have been learned so
we you don't want to start on picking
this complicated Constitution I think
the coronation will be very interesting
because because one of the core
coronation owes is to uphold the
reformed Protestant Faith but but that's
to come but I think he's had a very
remarkable week and and he despite the
grief has brilliantly launched himself
as the Monarch Wesley Laura thank you
very much indeed
well ahead of Monday's State funeral we
have more details of the day's events
they've been announced today
55 on Monday morning the bearer party
will begin to move the Queen's coffin
from Westminster Hall to the gun
Carriage the king the Queen's children
and the Queen's grandchildren will all
walk behind in A procession to
Westminster Abbey
at 11AM the funeral service begins
at 11 55 that service ends with a
two-minute silence
and at 12 15 the procession leaves the
Abbey makes its way through Central
London
and at one o'clock the coffin is moved
from the gun Carriage to the state
hearse and driven to Windsor Castle
at four o'clock in the afternoon the
committal service will be held at Saint
George's Chapel
and at 7 30 in the evening a private
service will take place where the queen
will be buried alongside the Duke of
Edinburgh in the King George VI Chapel
the Metropolitan Police say the policing
operation around the Queen's funeral is
the biggest in the forces history
Deputy assistant commissioner Stuart
cundy says it even surpasses the London
Olympics when 10 000 officers were on
duty every day
this will be the single largest policing
operation for an event that the Met
place has ever undertaken and I think
it's ever likely to undertake we will
have thousands of officers engaged not
just from the map please but from forces
up and down the United Kingdom
first and foremost our priority is to
ensure there is a safe and secure State
funeral
there will be tens of thousands of
people in London here to pay their
respects
and you will see a highly visible
policing presence across London not just
around Westminster Abbey
and Westminster Hall but along the Route
all the way up to Wellington arch before
Majesty this queen heads to Windsor
let's speak now to Steve Park an
International Security analyst who
worked on security at the London
Olympics he also served as a royal and
diplomatic Protection Officer
good evening Mr Park
um
what would you say about the scale of
the operation and the difficulty that is
facing the met and indeed all of the
police forces that are being brought
into to reinforce them
well it's certainly multi-complex
um I think Thames Valley Metropolitan
Police uh the work out of London
Scotland Yard will have had quite a lot
of
um let's say help from other events that
have been going on weddings and such
like in the in the in the past they will
be calling in mutual support from all
police forces throughout the UK which
has been a structural Support over the
last few years
at the moment uh the Queen's lying in
state is known as operation Marquee uh
we won't go into what the other
operations are called but this is on an
unprecedented precedented scale yes the
Olympics was large but one of the
problems here or one of the things which
uh come into play is dovetailing all of
the dignitaries that will be coming from
around the world and that's what will
make this one of the largest security
events I think the globe has ever seen
not just the UK
well there are several different aspects
of this aren't there there are there is
counter-terrorism there is management of
crowd and a point you've just mentioned
the management of the protection of the
many leaders and heads of States who are
coming in to London
um is it right that they uh are not
being allowed to bring their own
protection operation that is all now
going to be born by uh the met and
British police forces
uh it's it's complicated because one
gives too much information away if one
says too much
um but certainly uh some of the larger
heads of state will be able to bring
their own Security in as they always
have done and that's mutual respect
um with one country and another
I.E for example America
um no doubt President Biden will come in
with some of his security might not be
as beefed up as we've seen in the past
because there's already a ring of Steel
in London and there will be several
other rings of Steel as we've we've
started to know uh that kind of thing
that London could do very effectively
lock down streets in in moments and uh
and I think that's what the met in
particular has been practicing
um like I said they've had plenty of
practice with 2012 uh the Olympics and
and it's been some time since that event
um you know I've heard a lot of people
say that this is this has happened quite
quickly but this is a well-established
operational plan
that they have tweaked over the years to
understand where the problems might come
from you spoke about terrorism of course
that's got to be considered because that
one that would be one of the tick boxes
on the operational plan at the moment
um the uh the Threat Level will be
raised to substantial uh to cover this
whole period let alone just the funeral
of course one of the um obviously you
quite rightly can't go too far into the
security of leaders and so on but of
course one other side of this is crowd
management
is the expectation that this is going to
dwarf pretty much any similar event in
London yeah well there's nothing like a
good British crowd is there to all cue
in a straight line behind each other
um and and well that's the way uh we are
um and and it seems
um it's working like that at the moment
obviously there's going to be a lot of
stewards there's going to be a lot of
people that have been will be giving
advice out as to how far they are down
the queue
um to people that don't understand
location at which they may be
um in in the queues which we are seeing
at the moment they are certainly
unprecedented we've we've never seen
anything like these queues and I think
that the uh the Met police are looking
for these cues to expand considerably in
the next few days that's what I just
heard from your last report from uh from
from the uh metropolitan police officer
we just heard from there's certainly
need to put the allowance in so that an
influx of people that do come in uh one
of the problems here we have crowd
control
uh one of the problems with crowd
control is
um is bad control how do they
effectively deal with bags how do they
effectively deal with searching people
uh that will need to be taken aside how
do we deal with suspects
um are there people on watch list these
are all considerations that the police
will will take very very seriously and
it will be much bigger considerations
groups which may want to interfere with
the goings-on
it only takes one person to disrupt
um what what could be a very well
organized operational plan if it goes
off like all the other operational plans
have done in the last years
uh Mr Paul thank you so much indeed for
your time this evening
thank you
the royal family is of course a family
but it's not unfair perhaps also to call
it a multi-million pound family business
King Charles and Prince William have
inherited hundreds of millions of pounds
in Public Funding and private wealth
however they'll only pay tax on a
voluntary basis
a business correspondent Paul Kelso
analyzes the Royal finances as the crown
could face precious to streamline with a
nation already facing a cost of living
crisis
with the Queen's death fortunes as well
as titles passed down the line of
succession so it's worth reminding
ourselves where the money comes from the
royal family is funded by three main
revenue streams The Sovereign Grant the
largest which is worth 86 million pounds
last year and the duchy of Lancaster
Worth 22 million pounds both of which
will fund the king and the duchy of
Cornwall worth 24 million pounds which
will now fund William as Heir and Prince
of Wales Now The Sovereign Grant is
drawn from revenue generated by the
crown estate a 15 billion pound
portfolio of property and land three
courses of which goes to the exchequer
and the rest to pay for the crown and
while it was worth 86 million pounds
last year the queen spent 102 million
let's have a look at how that breaks
down 64 million pounds was spent on
maintaining the Royal palaces almost 50
million of that went on the
refurbishment of Buckingham Palace 27.5
million went on paying almost 500
members of Staff four and a half million
on travel and More Than 3 million on gas
and electricity the king also gets
revenue from the 600 million pound duchy
of Lancaster estate that was worth 22
million pounds last year which the queen
used to fund core members of the family
including Princess Anne prince Andrew
and Prince Edward now the king will only
pay income tax on this if like his
mother he volunteers to
as Prince of Wales William will enjoy
the Surplus from the one billion pound
duchy of Cornwallis state that includes
the oval cricket ground and was worth 24
million pounds last year it is exempt
from corporation tax and capital gains
tax and income tax will again be
voluntary
that was the presumed main beneficiary
of his mother's will the king will also
inherit immense private wealth including
Sandringham and bowel moral the queen
owned privately as part of an estate
worth an estimated 350 million pounds
but the detail will remain private as
uniquely Royal Wills do not have to go
to probate it's the process by which
they become public and the King will not
pay inheritance tax gifts from Monarch
to Monarch are exempt and there's a
small matter of more than a dozen
palaces and Residences around the
country six of them in London plus
Windsor Castle are publicly maintained
but he also has homes in gloucestershire
Wales and Burke Hall up in Scotland plus
the inherited Balmoral and Sandringham
in Norfolk
Royal funding is a deal between the
palace and Parliament and by association
the public but King Charles ascending in
the cost of living crisis May face
greater scrutiny than his mother of what
is appropriate for a modern Monarch and
what counts as excess
the King has this evening spoken of his
personal duty to protect the diversity
of our country as Laura was saying a
moment ago and he said this during a
meeting with faith leaders
30 representatives of various religions
gathered for a reception in Buckingham
Palace
I've always thought of them
of Britain as a community of communities
that has led that has led me to
understand that the Sovereign has an
additional duty
less formally recognized but to be no
less diligently discharged
it is the duty to protect the diversity
of our country
including by protecting the space for
Faith itself I am determined as king to
preserve and promote those principles
across all communities and for all
beliefs with all my heart
let's return to that cue earlier we've
seen those who made it to the front
people further back in the queue and as
usual there is nobody further back in
the queue than Skies Matthew Thompson
who joins us now Matthew I uh these are
called James Brown the hardest working
man in Showbiz I think you're the
hardest working man in news right now
what what's it like back there
I tell you the tragedy of covering the
queue this long is that I've spent
longer in the queue than anyone else
without getting the benefit of seeing
the queen lying Instead at the end of it
but look it's all in the name of news
and current affairs that's why we love
it it's quite an update
up here here at the back of the queue
welcome once again to the back of the
queue the biggest back of the queue that
we've seen in the three days certainly
that I've been covering I have to say
but as I say upbeat atmosphere in spite
of the fact that if you're going to
believe the government's estimates
anyway it could be as long as 24 hours
in the queue and yet still as you can
see people are here in their droves I
have to say signs here
actually on site say the estimate is
much more like 14 plus hours rather than
24. certainly that's the hope that many
people here are clinging to that they're
not quite going to be doing this for 24
hours but they are going to have to
strap themselves in for a bit of a long
haul I just want to see if we can maybe
speak to some of the people in the queue
guys unfortunately you're live on Sky
News
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right so I told you they were upbeat
does anyone want to explain to me why
you felt motivated enough to come out
and wait in a queue for 14 hours
so it's about being here yes are you
prepared to wait 24 hours if you have to
definitely the whole way through the
whole way through we're in it for the
long haul and we might see pet William
if we stick it out for tomorrow that's a
good point I've timed it have you got
snacks with you we have good water yes
something to wrap up warm yes good so
you're well prepared excellent you're
already behind in the queue
so there you have it I suppose what we
should really be doing is checking in
with them in 24 hours time and seeing if
they're still quite so upbeat as they
are now but I suppose some practical
tips you just heard me Trot through a
few of them out is the government say
make sure you've got snacks make sure
you've got water also do wrap up warm
because the temperatures tonight are
going to drop
it's going to go down to about eight
degrees according to my weather forecast
and also if you are turning up at this
time as many people still are arriving
in the droves do be prepared that you
might be in this one for the Long Haul
Matthews stay well stay warm
joining
joining me now is the writer and
historian James Hawes author of the
shortest history of England and
Brilliant Isles the story of Britain
through ART music buildings and
literature good evening Mr Halls good
evening thank you thank you very much
for joining us
um over the last week
we've had lots of music we've had lots
of buildings and we've heard a lot from
Shakespeare
um it's interesting that these things
have not really just been background
have they they've been part of the
script by which I guess the Royal
household has tried to communicate uh to
us in various ways
yes I mean the new King has clearly
signaled that he he is a man of culture
who wants to be seen as that and he you
know ending his ending his uh elegy for
his own mother with the words from
Hamlet so he the culture is going to be
Frontier flights of Angels Sing you to
your arrest absolutely absolutely
so culture is going to be front and
center and it's it's going to be vitally
important to us because as we all know
there's this buzzword culture wars going
around a lot today and the new king
spoke just then on on here on the
television of of this country as a
community of communities and his great
job is going to be to to try and hold
that together
in the face of what are deep flaws and
deep divisions so culture will be
vitally important and one of the things
was said to me today I'm speaking to you
from Cardiff is that during his speech
to the Senate here someone said to me a
very well connected uh member of the
Welsh establishment said at least he
didn't refer to us as a principality he
does seem to be better informed than his
political Masters so these gestures they
may seem to be just gestures but culture
matters and making the right cultural
gesture has probably never been more
important than that because just as your
your previous
um spot said he's
his finances may come under closer
um looking closely essentially than his
mothers were and so might his whole role
as as demonic of what is in his own
words a community of communities and
what is after all you know we're
actually quite a strange country we're
not a single nation like France or Spain
University we are four very different
nations and he's king of all I thought
forgive me I I thought it was very
telling
um and by the way correct me if I'm
wrong about this I I think I heard a
Welsh harp uh in the Synod there and I
thought it was very telling do you think
that that sort of well literally that
note uh is the sort of thing that would
strike a resonance with people in Wales
or will they
take it for granted
it will certainly strike a note in the
sensor it shows someone's thinking about
things at least and shows someone caring
and in in the same way as you know that
the the the the the the Royal the
Scottish part of the Great ceremonies
we've seen in the last few days was
really invented by Sir Walter Scott
um 100 years after the acts of Union in
order to cement this sense that we
really were linked by a culture and
that's going to be if anything the thing
that can hold us together because as I
say we are not one people and if
anything can hold us together it will be
the sense of a shared culture
to what extent do you think that some of
the pageantry is in a way working uh for
the Royal household
um you know I guess that though some
people looking at
you know all these chats dressed in red
and lots of gold braid and feathers in
hats and so on might say well what's
that all about what that what's that got
to do with the modern world but of
course there will be other people who
will say this is an indication of a
continuity
what do you think it really does for us
well I'm afraid I I think we have to
remember one thing and that was this
whole notion of regiments of God's
parading cannons shooting the Scots
bagpipes piping and so forth is only 120
years old it's not really an ancient
tradition you know this these islands
are full of genuinely ancient wonderful
traditions and wonderful things but this
Royal Funeral business is in fact not
one of them it's a modern invention it
was invented the Queen Victoria and it
only became a so-called tradition for
the funeral of April the seventh so it's
really no older it's not even as old as
some pancreas station it's not really a
a very a great ancient right of these
islands it's something which was
invented at the height of the British
Empire to cement
the United Kingdom as the headquarters
of a world Empire now this is precisely
the problem of Charles faces because we
all know the Empire's gone but this
Curious Thing the United Kingdom only
forged together in 1801 as I say as the
headquarters of a world Empire at War
it's now the Empire's gone the question
is will that Imperial headquarters
construct really last much longer I mean
let's not forget Ireland left us
by Force of Arms
exactly 100 years ago
and Winston Churchill who many people
think was the greatest of our Cottages
ever before the first world war he was
saying the only future for the United
Kingdom was that it had to become a
Federation of genuinely equal Nations
each sending representatives to London
because he felt in 1912 that his
Imperial headquarters itself might be
crumbling
set against that
um one of the things that we've been
talking a lot about on this program each
evening has been the intervention of
people on the streets people who have
well we the big thing of the last couple
days being accused but prior to that
there have been the familiar site of
flowers laid outside palaces there a new
thing which is silence but a kind of
spontaneous Applause which
um I think I I I I would detect maybe
it's because I'm a football supporter as
something that the crowds have started
to borrow from football supporters and I
wonder if um
against not against but in addition to
what you said we're seeing the sort of
evolution of what you might call popular
rituals which all four nations share
because we've seen the same thing in uh
Belfast in Edinburgh uh in Cardiff and
in London
I think that's that's a fascinating idea
which I hadn't thought of him I've seen
it and but it does it shows something
which is that we are actually very
similar in many ways to one another it's
just that we have to get if we're going
to stay together frankly we're going to
need a political Arrangement which makes
more reference to to the differences
between us as well and our wish to be
together is clearly very powerful
people have as you say spontaneously
gone out they've queued up they put
flowers they are queuing up by the mile
now because we have a great feeling of
wanting to be more than just individuals
and I think more than just individual
Nations as well but we've got to get the
politics right and that's going to be
Charles's
the well the great to the great
challenge of his Reign perhaps not for
him personally because he's not allowed
to intervene in politics obviously but
the political challenge coming is going
to be whether
in his Reign at this thing called the
United Kingdom itself can stay together
James horse thank you so much indeed for
your time and we will see how that works
out
for decades where nothing happens and
there are weeks where decades happen so
the famous quote attributed to Lenin
goes and this week has been one like no
other
here's a look back at some of the
extraordinary images that have
punctuated a momentous week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]